Yeah.
Now time,
um,
as we'll find out,
many of the titles of the novels,
I'll actually,
uh,
from,
from very,
um,
conomical work or you know,
very ancient works.
In the case of Faulkner.
Um,
in the case of Hemingway,
um,
the title is from the book of common prayer,
give us peace in our time or Lord.
Um,
so it's very much is a meditation on war and peace and thinking about what
happens in war and also thinking about what happens,
uh,
when we have theoretical piece.
Um,
but maybe war is still going on in some fashion.
So it was really,
um,
praying for peace.
Um,
I should talk a little bit about the publication history of,
you know,
time.
Um,
yes,
uh,
very,
um,
interesting and complicated publication history.
Um,
initially,
um,
a lot of the vignettes from in our time out,
whether we would can't vignettes,
Hemingway cars,
chapters,
um,
those were published first.
So they were Polish in the little reviews and this one is actually called a
little review.
Um,
and um,
so there are some published in there.
And,
um,
some of the stories actually,
uh,
were also published,
um,
in the low reviews.
And this one is called,
um,
what we now called Indian camp,
that we'll be talking about today.
That was published in the Trans Atlantic Review.
Um,
and the first edition of in our time was actually published in Paris.
it was published by the three mountains press,
um,
very,
you know,
handcrafted look,
um,
in fact it was handcrafted,
only 30 pages.
So,
you know,
really just all the vineyards,
all the chapters.
Uh,
we're in that edition.
Um,
and only 170 copies were printed.
So,
you know,
this is really the very beginning of Hemingway's Korea and it's really
interesting to see that he bears how he started out.
Um,
someone who really was thinking of 170 people reading his,
his work.
Um,
and then,
um,
but even though only 170 copies were printed,
it actually got very,
very warm responses right away.
And it is actually amazing to think that it got picked up right away by,
um,
by Fitzgerald who wrote his editor,
Maxwell Perkins.
Um,
as Scribner's,
um,
saying that,
the vineyards are really remarkable and I'll look him up right away.
He's still real thing.
So,
you know,
this was back in 1924 when Hemingway was total unknown.
Um,
so the,
uh,
addition,
um,
first American edition,
uh,
was powered by Bonnie and liberal,
right.
Um,
this is Hemingway's first publisher.
He would then move onto Scribner's.
Um,
and Scribner's is the publisher that controls on the copyright to the,
the,
the hemming,
all of Hemingway novels.
Um,
but he started out with,
um,
Barney and liberal rate and there were a few more and um,
not just within yes now,
but a few of the stories were included in this edition 1950,
25 edition of in our time.
Um,
but,
uh,
still a very handmade look.
Um,
and,
uh,
Hemingway did not have a very happy relation to Bonnie and they were right.
Um,
and mostly having to do with the structure,
um,
of the,
of in our time.
Um,
so he,
um,
on April 20th second he wrote to his good friend,
author John Dos Passos saying,
and this is George Kaufman is here.
And she claims they want to cut it all out.
Indian camp story cut the in our time chapters.
Jesus,
I feel all shot to hell about it.
Of course they can do it because the stuff is so tight and hard and everything
hands on everything else.
So this is 1925 but already we can see,
um,
the Hemingway that we recognize later,
somebody who love
his material wants as material to be tight and hard and everything hanging on
everything else.
But still it is a very,
very strange claim given the fact that in fact the publication history of in our
time suggest that it wasn't conceived of.
And it wasn't initially published as on one piece.
It was actually published separately.
So I'm very,
but meanwhile,
Hemingway is going to claim that in fact,
he wants everything on one piece.
So,
um,
I think that this is something that we should really think about,
you know,
was you certainly take Hemingway very seriously.
Um,
that is insisting that everything is hanging together.
but also maybe entertaining the possibility,
uh,
that may be the loser than he would like to thing or the he claims.
Um,
so let's think about,
rather than taking him away completely,
um,
at his word,
let's just say,
um,
that,
uh,
we'll think of the narrative structure of in our time as a puzzling structure,
um,
that,
and this is something that we can say,
I mean,
there's not much dispute about it.
Looks,
doesn't look like,
um,
you know,
short story collection doesn't look like anything else that we've read.
Um,
so this is very unusual structure of the stories being interspersed with the
chapters.
Um,
and the seems to be,
uh,
an apparent disjunction between these two.
Um,
and this also kind of very rapid shift,
um,
of location and perspective,
between those pieces that are said in wartime Europe.
Um,
and those,
the set in peacetime,
um,
America in the Midwest,
so it doesn't work as a linear,
streamlined kind of narrative.
It doesn't look like the traditional novel.
It doesn't look like a collection of short stories.
So in the Sunday to think about a puzzle over.
Um,
so what I like to do today is actually to give Hemingway the benefit of the
doubt.
Um,
he's saying that everything hangs together so less we three pieces as if they
did in fact hand together.
Okay.
So,
you know,
this is uh,
an experiment in reading.
Um,
you know,
we can,
we can never prove for sure that they do in fact hand together,
but because Hemingway is so emphatic about it,
um,
let's just do this little experiment or reading three,
two stories and then one chapter,
one into chapter,
um,
as if they all belong together as a unit.
But to say that it's also,
it's also the say that,
you know,
you guys can experiment with other clusters,
right?
You know,
the cluster is this is a possible cluster.
You can experiment with other possible clusters.
So,
you know,
when it comes to writing papers business,
a great opportunity to try out to see which goes with what,
um,
so the three that I'm proposing to read together,
this was,
well,
Indian camp,
we know for a fact that that was published separately.
So let's not forget that for a moment.
Okay.
But still given that it was initially published in the Trans Line Review,
less group it with the attitude.
Um,
and in chapter two,
and then doctor,
doctor and doctor doctor's wife to reason that,
um,
those three hang together in my mind,
is that they actually have the same kind of thematic,
um,
uh,
the,
the work on the same thematic registered and they also work on the same,
um,
kind of macro micro registers,
that we were talking about last time.
So the Macro Register,
um,
is that there is the tension between the Anglos and the native Americans.
Right.
Both of these stories,
let's leave on the chapter first because it is obviously not something else.
Um,
but in income and a doctor in the doctor's wife,
um,
they both are about the relation,
they trained Anglos and then the native Americans.
Um,
and about the tension conflict,
um,
between them,
and both stories.
Um,
also share,
uh,
some important similarity on the micro register.
Um,
the Indian camp obviously is about the phenomenon of pain.
I'm in about violence to oneself,
about injury.
About injury to others about,
um,
about violence to oneself,
and the doctor and the doctor's wife is about,
or potential violence,
right?
You know,
fight could break out in their storage.
Um,
but it doesn't,
so in some sense is the opposite of Indian camp.
It is about the possibility of violence that has been avoided.
So,
you know,
just on that basis it would seem that there's some kind of relation between
them.
Um,
so let's look at the macro register.
The first,
I mean,
it's not as macro is,
you know,
the history of World War One.
Um,
but there's macro in the sense that is really is about important sociological,
um,
Platte valley,
United States.
Um,
the stories as said,
um,
in Houghton Bay,
Ashley,
this is where,
um,
the Hemingway family with go further some of occasions is in Michigan.
Um,
and,
um,
the native Americans are legit way,
uh,
as an NRB.
Um,
the actually the proofer a destination by them,
but mostly,
you know,
the Ojibwe I think is the more common name.
Um,
very well known group of very important group of native Americans.
So there's a whole book written about them.
Um,
and um,
and I also,
so this is the,
this is the background to the macro history,
um,
of the two stories.
Um,
and I like to introduce,
um,
three,
additional perspectives now on the micro level a,
which is talking about the phenomenon of pain and injury and violence and so on.
And,
um,
you might or might not have,
read these people,
but they've very influential people,
including a,
obviously a great painter,
uh,
writing about pain and injury and so on.
So let's just pick Elaine scary Susan Sontag and even more.
Um,
so let's just begin with Elaine.
Scary.
Um,
this is a book that came out in the eighties,
1980s,
a,
it's called a body in pain.
Um,
and,
um,
a lot of it I'm Ashley has to do and she's done extensive research with an and
using the archives at Amnesty International,
uh,
looking at the phenomenon of paying this a consequence of torture.
Um,
and the argument about the book is that,
um,
that when,
uh,
prisoners torture,
when there's really nothing in the world open to them except for the experience
of pain,
um,
then they lose the ability,
to express themselves.
They lose the ability to have any kind of linguistic relation to the world,
including the linguistic relation of being,
to able to describe your own pain.
So what she argues is that there's a breakdown of language under extreme
conditions or pain.
That pain basically
brings down our world.
And the first thing,
the most important thing to go is our language because the coin into the lane
scary.
It is language that angers and constitutes our well.
So,
um,
it is an argument about,
the power of pain and its ability to dehumanize us because,
uh,
it takes away our ability to do the most fundamentally human thing,
namely to speak,
use language.
Um,
so this is one end of the spectrum.
in thinking about pain on the other end of the spectrum of very,
very different kind of philosophy,
um,
is um,
the,
uh,
public intellectual.
Susan Sontag in my have a she that she is,
she died,
um,
for you.
Uh,
but um,
her work has been really,
really important,
uh,
for,
for many,
for decades really.
Um,
and one of whom Moses,
uh,
one of the best known bugs is called regarding the pain of others.
She really has a complete different and tig on pain,
um,
from Elaine.
Scary.
She argues that,
um,
rather than thinking about the phenomenon of paying the self as a kind of
experiential reality for us,
um,
she was interested in how um,
the observation or pain in others,
uh,
gives us pleasure that in some sense we are affirmed with Afirma on being we are
from ourselves.
We affirmed the fact that we are not feeling pain when we see pain in others are
very tough and in many ways of kind of disturbing argument,
um,
that argue her basic sense of the world is that we affirm our own being by being
able to tell ourselves across from others.
So when we see someone in acute pain,
we know that we are someone else,
that we are what we are because we're not going through that pain.
So there's kind of indirect pleasure from seeing the pain and others and speed
in the cover of her book.
Um,
so it's a very disturbing,
but something to keep in mind.
Um,
and,
uh,
the,
both of those models I want to call to your attention,
uh,
because I think that that Hemingway,
um,
actually,
uh,
has something to say,
um,
to each of them.
Ashley and I will encourage you in session to think about how he would help me
with the se to Elaine.
Scary where Hemingway was say to Susan Sontag.
You,
no,
he obviously wasn't writing for them,
but given the fact that he has written stories that have to do with pay,
how he would respond to those,
um,
to those theories.
Um,
but I think that Hemingway is actually closer to this,
um,
to the painter munch,
and the very celebrated,
uh,
painting the scream.
Um,
and it's really about paying as a sound,
right?
So paying,
coming out as a screen.
Um,
and it is a corrective to Elaine,
scary in the sense that even though we might not be able to speak,
uh,
when we're in acute pain,
we still are able to express ourselves because we can just cry out even though
is no linguistic is not the word that we're saying.
The very fact that something is coming out of a suggest that um,
the capacity for expression has an a completely broken down.
Um,
we were just not especially interested in thinking about what the screen will do
to others.
Right.
You know,
so basically this is just somebody who is crying out in pain and probably not
bodily injury either,
but just psychic pain,
just screaming up.
Um,
we're just not putting into the picture.
what the scream would do to other people listening to that screen.
So I would like to see a Hemingway as collaborating with mortgage.
Weren't,
is giving us the scream coming out of the person who is suffering.
And in the end cam is Hemingway's extended meditation on the phenomenon of the
screen screen on what the screen would do to people who are completely
vulnerable to that sound or pain.
Um,
usually we just think of ourselves as being vulnerable to pain,
but we are also vulnerable to the standard pain.
So this is a very different model from the one suggested by Susan Sontag.
You know,
I'm already giving you a bit of an argument about having way we'll say says.
Um,
sometimes it's really thinking about pain as a kind of a visual measure that to
other people we see other people suffering and we get some visual pleasure
having way is about all his rape pain that we again,
as a consequence of our ears being helplessly open to the pain of others.
So this basically a very different important difference between the eye and the
ear.
And I think most people would agree that we can shut our eyes.
You know,
we don't have to see something if don't want you out.
We couldn't really shut out use.
Um,
we can remove ourselves to greater distance and shut out.
You use that way.
But if we're in enabling of someone who is screaming can really shut out,
we use,
um,
so Indian camp is really about what happens when someone cannot shut his or her
ears,
uh,
to a screen.
So,
um,
it's about a woman giving birth.
Um,
and uh,
next father who's a doctor coming to attend to that woman,
um,
is about,
uh,
who Anglo doctor coming to a very close knit native American community to take
care of them.
American woman.
And they're very primitive conditions.
Um,
but having ways,
whereas a lot of time,
Ashley,
not just talking about Anglo and Indian relations,
but also about the relations among native Americans,
right?
So this is how the men react to the woman giving birth and screaming.
The man had moved up the road to sit in the dark and smoke of range of the
noises she made.
She screamed as nick and the two Indians followed his father into the Shanti.
Um,
so
this is actually the baseline for Hemingway is that the scream is unbearable
even to her own community.
This is someone who is actually inflicting pain and injury on her own native
American community,
not because of any conflict with them.
Right?
So this is very important fact to know this is not a socio political conflict,
socio economic conflict.
It is not the conflict between two different ethnic groups.
It is an involuntary conflict within one close knit ethnic group.
The woman can help screaming.
She can't help causing pain to her own community.
So the man are trying to do the best they can to get themselves out of the way,
um,
of the,
of the painful,
um,
screaming that they're hearing.
Um,
and we can think about what follows from this given from this baseline.
and actually there are two outcomes.
Um,
and one outcome is actually,
um,
very much predicated on the importance of ethnic difference.
So here are the native American men,
uh,
being completely overwhelmed and helpless in the phase of the screen.
But one person,
one person who's not affected by this room,
why is he not the fact that by those screens are not important?
I don't hear them because they are not important.
Who is it says that
the doctor exactly.
Thank you.
Is Nick's bother.
So what enables him,
what is it that insulates him from the screen?
It seems that if there was something else that can override that's,
um,
something else that is more important to you,
then the immediacy of that song.
It can serve as a protective shell.
And as it turns out,
it is the doctor's professional identity does,
he's able to explain to nick.
Um,
what she's going through is something called Labor.
The baby wants to be born,
the baby's trying to be born.
She was trying her best and that the baby would be born.
Um,
he has the completely coherent explanation as to why she's going through the
pain and he has a completely coherent explanation as to why she's screaming
right now.
So the coherence of that explanation and the fact that he is professionally
equipped to put an end to this way of the fact that he as a doctor can just
perform.
This is,
they're in operation.
So the screen,
we'll stop.
Um,
both his ability to explain a phenomenon and its ability to put an end to the
phenomenon dose to work together so that the scream wild,
a fact of life is not going to be devastating to the doctor.
And we all know that,
right?
If the office we're going to be devastated by the screams,
they won't be nothing.
They will be able to operate.
So a very important feature of the professional identity of a doctor is that
they should be able to launch to take a lot of sensory input that would be
unbearable to other people and be able to put that sensory input in his place.
Um,
being able to explain it is being to put it away and being able to cope with it.
And here's the Golfer being able to cope with that.
So this is one possible outcome is that this basically a kind of neutralization
of the swim.
Um,
it is not piercing.
It is not those stadium,
but the process of neutralization doesn't always take place.
This is the outcome.
Two,
um,
the doctor,
Nick's father is congratulating himself,
um,
you know,
that he's performed the operation.
Uh,
he's able to do this,
this area and was just a jackknife on.
He's going to write it up for the medical journals.
It's very,
very happy as a doctor.
Uh,
he feels very much a therm.
And then there's one other development.
Um,
he looks at the prow father,
um,
the person who are to be the proud father.
Uh,
he quickly turns away and tells me so we know what the outcome to get.
Um,
what happens when someone who is not insulated by his professional identity?
it helps mostly subject to the screen.
His throw hadn't culled from ear to ear.
The blood had stroll down into a pool where this bar set.
So this is very extreme reaction.
Um,
I honestly don't know how common this is that a father,
uh,
we just go to the extreme of taking his own life,
um,
because he can't really take the pain of his wife.
Um,
but it's the opposite model from the Susan Sontag model is not taking pleasure
from the pain of others,
but being completely devastated,
being completely destroyed by the pain of others to such an extent that you want
to take your biological life because you're in the psychic life has been so
devastated by what you cannot bear to go through anymore.
Um,
so this is,
um,
and extreme case of empathy.
Um,
the husband empathizing with the wife feeling the pain of his wife to such a
standard.
It's almost as if the pain is doing more to him than it is actually doing,
um,
to his wife.
Um,
so this is one way to think about,
um,
pain,
how natural it is,
uh,
is naturalized because it is,
has no,
uh,
socio economic explanation to it.
It's just a fact of life that women will give birth and it is a fact of life
that they suffered tremendously when they give birth.
And it's also a fact of life that when they suffer other,
uh,
likely to suffer as well.
Right?
So this is kind of a transitive relation or pain spreading out and becoming more
and more common,
becoming more and more of condition,
the universal condition of life.
Um,
because they basically is no boundary between the pain of one person,
um,
and what someone else is likely to go through.
So we can say that what we see in Indian camp,
um,
yes to some extent a story that gestures in two directions.
On the one hand there's a lot of interests and the tension between native
Americans and um,
Anglo Americans.
Um,
that's not unimportant.
It pulls in one direction.
It also pulls in another direction and they put in the other direction other,
the micro register in terms of pain.
Um,
that really the most fundamental drama is almost regardless of the relation,
the train Anglos and native Americans,
you do it to everyone and you do it every time you go through pain.
Every time you go into labor,
the son,
this is going to happen.
Um,
so it was kind of a naturalization the pain as a kind of universal condition.
let's look at the intern chapter,
um,
and test this possibility.
Whether or not Hemingway is really wanting to explore the phenomenon that does
nothing to be done about pain,
that it is the most fundamental fact of life,
that it is as natural as the sense of hearing.
Um,
I think that in Indian county,
um,
this sense that,
you know,
just as we can help the fact that we have pair of ears,
we can help the fact that we're going to be vulnerable to the sounds of pain may
by others.
Um,
in terms of to Hemingway is I'm testing this possibility,
but the same kind of play between the macro and the micro register.
Um,
so the macro register is the Glencoe Turkish ward.
We've really looked at last time.
Um,
and this is about the evacuation of the Greek Civil Orleans,
uh,
when the Turkish army,
um,
was just advancing on them.
Um,
so it's the largest possible contacts,
um,
kind of,
large scale geopolitical warfare.
That's the macro context.
Um,
but it's interesting that in this one fridge,
one paragraph,
um,
Hemingway has transition to something else.
So let's just read this paragraph.
A green Camry hooded along the procession.
Women and kids were in the cause.
Crowds of mattresses,
mirrors,
sewing machines,
bundles.
There was a woman having a kid with a young girl holding a blended over her and
crying scares,
like looking at it,
it rain all through the evacuation.
Okay.
So obviously this is classic anyway,
about as much as bad into this one short paragraph as could be pat into any
short paragraph,
uh,
beginning with the macro context,
um,
of the Iraqi oil,
the evacuation of Greek civilians.
Um,
we move on to something that clearly is picking up on the theme La Residues from
the first story from Indian camp,
a woman having a baby.
Um,
and it follows the same structure as well,
not just a woman having a baby,
but someone watching that,
observing that,
um,
and um,
being terrified of that side of life.
Right?
So we
no mother,
you know,
even though we do know that Indian camp was published separately,
I think that we have to ran Hemingway.
The truth of his statement that the stories and the into chapters have really
connected.
I mean the connected after the fact in the chapters,
at least this particular one is obviously written,
um,
as a continuation of a meditation on the pain of childbirth.
Um,
and not just the pain of childbirth as experienced by the person who is going
that through that phenomenon going through the experience,
but also as
an observational painting,
um,
in someone who's just on looker.
Well,
it does to the onlooker.
Um,
it's the same kind of dynamics being terrified,
being scared,
sync,
looking at there.
So it's not quite as extreme as the husband calling his own throat,
but being scared,
safe looking.
I will say that is fairly extreme response as well,
um,
to the phenomenon of childbirth.
So Hemingway's obviously interested in people being homeless,
being unable to protect themselves when they're face with the injury of others.
Um,
is the lack of protective insulation.
That is the phenomenon that Hemingway is interested in is why is it that only a
few people,
only people were professional credentials,
like the uppers,
um,
are well protected.
Um,
and that loads of those as they tend to be open to injury,
open to violence from others.
Um,
in,
in a very helpless way.
Um,
and it's because of that basic configuration,
openness to the injury,
openness to the pain of others that Hemingway moves on to the last line of the
spillover vignette.
It rained all through the evacuation on the face of it.
No connection whatsoever with the proceeded passage.
Right?
You know,
it was just about your documentation.
Um,
all of a sudden this,
this detail about reigning,
the only connection that I can think of,
and it's a conjecture on my thought,
is that Hemingway has so far been talking about human phenomena,
right?
War.
It's very much a manmade event.
Childbirth is the human manmade as well.
Uh,
and uh,
I mean there's natural,
but you know,
human beings have to bring it about,
um,
rain is truly a natural phenomenon that is without human input,
without human agency.
So what we see in this little vignette is a movement in the direction of
naturalization.
Uh,
by the time we get to the end of the Vignette,
we get a completely natural process without human input about which human beings
can do nothing,
right?
And this is the resting point.
This is the place that Hemingway wants us to get to a place where we are just
passive recipients of something that is coming to us.
Rain is something that just happens to us.
You know,
we just know that we know this.
We've just been through this.
Rain is something that happens to us.
We are passive recipients.
Something that happens to us,
the pain of others is natural in exactly the same way.
And we're also a passive recipients of the pain of others in the same way that
we are passive recipients of rain.
Um,
there,
there is one experiential register,
um,
that is very,
very human,
um,
that is almost independent of human agency.
Um,
it is uh,
an experience simply the fine by us as recipients,
as people who just stand there and things being visited upon us.
Um,
so this is um,
I think very much an affirmation.
A of the line of thinking already started in Indian camp is that no matter how
well protected we think we are,
um,
and the weather,
how good we are actually as what we set out to do.
And the doctor obviously is a great doc,
very,
very good offer.
Um,
no matter how good we are at what we set out to do,
um,
there is a limit to what that can accomplish in the world.
And expertise.
The professional expertise of the Darfur is always going to run up against the
kinds of natural limit and pain of childbirth is in fact that natural than it.
So,
um,
very much a concession,
in the direction of the naturalists of pain,
um,
and the kind of unavoidable intensity and unavoidable violence that they can do
to other people.
So let's look at,
um,
this,
this is basically just repeating summary.
Well,
I just,
that,
um,
let's look at,
uh,
move on to the doctor as after they want to go back and think about this.
Uh,
let's move on to the author and the doctor's wife.
and this one isn't on the face of it.
It really isn't so much about pain,
right?
It's not,
Oh,
if,
unless we think about guilt or shame as a kind of pain,
but there's nothing like extreme,
uh,
kind of,
um,
mind numbing mind destroying pain that we see,
uh,
in Indian camp.
Um,
so,
uh,
it is about the tensions,
the between Anglos and native Americans.
So,
you know,
we're back to the macro level about the color farm,
socio economic,
uh,
tension between two Avnet groups,
um,
and attention has to do with the locks that wash assurer,
that really belonged to the logging company.
Um,
that next father,
um,
claims,
uh,
and because they,
as far as he can see,
it's actually true that they belong to nobody.
So he's trying to,
his higher,
um,
the native American,
workers
day laborers are to cut up the wood.
Um,
and,
uh,
he gets into a row with the,
native American workers.
Uh,
dig Bolton is basically timed in him,
right?
You know,
rubbing it in that those logs are stolen,
that they don't belong to him,
um,
and he's doing something illegal.
So the professional data is getting more and more flustered as this conversation
goes on.
Um,
and it looks like something's going to happen.
Right.
And we know the deck is a very big man.
He's proud of that.
These sort of big man,
he's not afraid of getting into the site.
So the stage is set really for a real inter ethnic.
And um,
this is Ashley.
What I like to say,
um,
as,
uh,
the first step towards the end of the story,
which we know is actually a happy ending.
Um,
the stage is set for the fight to take place.
The fight doesn't take place.
What is it that stops the fight from taking place?
What is it that makes what might have seemed a natural scene of violence from
Ashley being less than agile?
Um,
that is to say preventable.
So preventable violence,
preventable injury.
This is what the story's about.
So,
um,
this is my candidate for the first step in that direction towards the resolution
of violence in the direction of peace,
which is at what Hemingway is praying,
praying for in this,
uh,
in,
in our stories.
Um,
the exact something of jetway addie laugh,
but Billy take sure,
look very serious.
He did not understand English,
but he has sweat all the time to,
I was going on,
he was fad with only a few hairs on the start,
like a Chinaman.
He picked up the two canned hoax.
Dicke picked up the access and they already took the salt down from the tree.
They started off and walked up past the cottage and out the back gate into the
woods.
Do left the gate open.
Billy [inaudible] went back and fastened.
Okay.
So I think it's a really fascinating portrait and for a writer who prides
himself on being completely economical,
actually some interesting details.
I can't for the life of me figure out what their point is for,
uh,
comparing Billy tapes show to a Chinaman.
Let's just the interest in data.
So,
you know,
it's something to think about.
I can offer you an explanation of why that they,
I do them,
uh,
is in there.
Um,
the only possible reason,
um,
is that,
uh,
having where really wants to highlight the fact that because he's not an English
speaker,
um,
therefore,
you know,
this all this is really great to him and I don't,
wouldn't put it past time in which there's resurrection.
The Greeks in this way,
English is Greg [inaudible] shore.
Um,
so it once again,
it looks squarely in the direction of inter ethnic conflict,
um,
and uh,
ranting primacy to that inter ethnic conflict.
Um,
and going so far as to say that,
you know,
that here is someone who really is completely not in the Anglo camp,
not sharing language about not even having that common grant.
Right.
But what is really odd,
and I think that that really is the point in emphasizing the date.
Obviously he's totally fluent in English.
Um,
Billy is not fluent.
The law cannot understand anything.
Um,
but even though he doesn't have language as to share common ground with the
ankles,
he nonetheless knows there's something about the chemistry and the atmosphere of
an incipient fight that people can pick up on even if they don't understand the
right.
So this is still Hemingway going some distance in the direction of naturalizing
conflict.
It is such a natural process that language as an artificial human invention is
not necessary.
It's not necessarily for us to understand that something is about to happen.
So the fact that Billy is completely,
fully incomprehension of the situation suggest that conflict conflict if it's
very deep and it's so deep that is the kind of a,
we have kind of a primitive apprehension.
Um,
obviously incipients um,
so well there's also interesting,
um,
is that asked the estimate as the native American Indian laborers leave,
they pick up all other tools that could be used as potential weapons,
right?
So they're not using those things yet as weapons of aggression or self defense
or anything like that.
They just still using those as,
as to as they've done the world,
they're going to take those things away still as tooth.
But the fact that David has left the gate open for me suggest that he's also
leaving open the possibility that those,
the Ken hoax,
um,
the saw,
the dose things that right now are serving only as useful tools could also be
used as weapons is leaving open that possibility.
Right?
So,
you know,
and he would be trees Ashley if those tools were to be put to a secondary and
more deadly use.
Um,
what is interesting is that Billy who doesn't understand English but who
completely understands the situation is the one who goes back and fastens the
Kate.
Right?
So this is a very important detail from Hemingway that it is someone who is
really,
has no personal relation,
has no,
you know,
ties really to the Anglos.
He's the one who actually
performs the important task of closing the gate.
So he's one piece maker coming from a very unexpected place.
But the fact that it is Billy who's performing that function suggested there's
almost a counterpoint to the natural violence.
Just as there's a kind of a natural tendency towards violence.
There's also a natural tendency to keeping the peace that both are firmly
embedded in us.
Both I'm primitive in us and primitive by primitive,
I mean very,
very powerful.
The more primitive they are,
the more DC if they are and more likely they are going to play out.
So being a peacemaker is a very,
um,
deep seated desire really in all of us,
and being played out in Billy.
And um,
so I'd like to thank,
um,
test another possibility.
Um,
who else is Billy being aligned with?
if Billy is going,
taking the first step,
uh,
to stop the conflict,
um,
is there anyone else in the story,
that's feeling the work for him?
Is there some put some,
some,
anyone else in the story?
Um,
that actually finishes the task that is began by the way.
and obviously if we turn to the ending of the story,
uh,
we see that this a very,
a crucial conversation,
uh,
between the author and the doctors.
Well,
I have two people who are named in the title of the story.
Uh,
deer.
I don't think,
I really don't think that anyone would really do think like that.
No,
no,
I can't really believe that anyone would do a thing so intensely.
And the doctors were saying that,
you know,
that Billy is that take is picking up a fight so he wouldn't have to pay the
medical bills after.
This is all intentional on the part of data that doesn't get getting into a
fight with me and that everything would be off between the two of them.
No medical bills to be paid.
Doctor's wife is saying no.
Um,
so she was saying that,
okay.
You know,
that's not likely.
Um,
the doctor stood up and put the shotgun in the corner behind the dresser.
You going out there?
His wife's that I think I'll move.
Who on?
The doctor said you seen neg?
You tell him his mother wants to see him.
Um,
it's an interesting
thing to say is,
is,
is not surprising for the wife to say,
okay.
You know,
as you'll see our son telling the come in,
um,
except right after she says that and the doctor goes out,
he slams the door.
Um,
and the wife catches her breath as he goes out and slams the door.
So let's think for a moment about the two things that the wife says.
One is that she does that take is picking a fight so that he wouldn't have to
pay the medical bills.
And the other thing that she says is if you see Nate tell him that I wanted to
see him and he should come in to see me.
What is if fact of saying that the doctor says that to nick,
what does mean do think says I want to go with you.
He doesn't want to go in to see his mother.
He doesn't want to go in the house to see his mother.
So if fat of the mother saying,
I want to see nick actually has the effect that is demonstrated in the ending of
the story is that nick is going to go with his father and we can think of a
better companion,
a better too for the mother to use to stop the doctor from getting into a fight
with his native American workers play.
As long as nick is there,
we know that he's never go in together into a fight.
So the way I'm reading the story,
um,
and you know,
honestly a conjectural reading,
um,
but this is the best the doctor's wife can do as a peacemaker is two engine.
The scenario in which a fight is highly unlikely to take place and it turns out
as she is an asset and engineering that scenario by telling them to come in to
see her,
she was succeeded in exactly achieving the outcome of the story.
Nick going off with his father to see the black squirrels,
no violence happening.
So we can say that the three,
the two stories and in the chapter that together,
all three of them
perform all around the meditation.
On violence and pain.
One pointing the direction of the naturalists of balance and pain.
The other pony in the equal naturalists are peace prevailing,
right?
That it doesn't have to be violence,
doesn't have to be pained.
Others paying for oneself doesn't have to be.
It could be stopped.
It can be prevented.
So this is,
I would say this is very typical structure in Hemingway,
um,
is to give us both meditation on both sides of the spectrum.
Um,
testing both,
both possibilities and,
um,
allowing the three to be in dialogue.
So,
you know,
as far as I can see,
I think the Hemingway is right,
that everything,
in fact,
hands on everything else.
Um,
and we really should see them in relation to one another.
So we'll come back on Thursday and we'll try it.
Another way of clustering the stories.